[Musique]
après un long parcours de sélection ils
ne sont plus que 71 finaliste à
participer à cette 28e édition du
championnat régional d'orthographe du
cm1 à la 3e ces jeunes candidats font
valoir leur maîtrise de la langue
française n'a choisi un texte extrait du
livre maxime la aux souvenirs textes et
chansons
écrit par sa fille expedite l'a observé
une dictée de 30 minutes qui raconte un
souvenir d'enfance de maxime laope sur
les courses hippiques qui se déroulait
au colorado
elle était elle était un peu long et il
y avait quelques mots je connais pas
mais après si on sort je m'attends pas à
gagner le veut parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de concurrents mais en vrai je pense à
des finalistes qui ont étonné par leur
qualité en orthographe et en grammaire
déjà à la correction les premières
copies montre le niveau d'ensemble très
bien préviens moi même je suis épaté de
voir des élèves de troisième qui font
une faute un quart s'est servi les
meilleurs d'entre eux sont ici
récompensés il espère bien briller une
année encore lors de la prochaine
édition
[Musique]